[Música]
les pasó alguna vez de estar parados en
frente de una góndola de yogur y no
saber qué elegir si el firme o el
bebible si llevar sabor vainilla
frutilla durazno balada maracuyá o
frutos del bosque frutos del bosque a
morir porque no hay nada más cool que
comer frutos del bosque estando en plena
pampa húmeda
pero quizás seguirán por este
supermercado y se pararon enfrente de
las hojas verdes en la verdulería
las miraste pensando esto será rúcula o
radicheta
agarraste la lechuga porque con esa no
te equivocas seguro
y continua este este recorrido puede
superar hasta llegar a la góndola de los
vídeos 16 metros de largo
arrancas a transitarla y ahi estan
mostachones fusiles de delitos
[Música]
la sopita de letras espagueti tallarín
y más abajo los tuyos los espagueti de
morrón los casas y te vas derechito a tu
casa y los arrancas a cocinar
hasta que entra tu pareja a la cocina
otra vez compraste los de color
pues de verdad te crees que esto tiene
morrón
pero se suma a la cocina
la luz de tus ojos tu nenito o nenita
les is mi amor te compre un surf
si no haces de los vídeos no lo quiero
definitivamente buscar que comer se
volvió un acto complejo
y confuso
a veces simplemente nos conformamos con
lo que hay pero otras veces
nos sentimos unos grandes estrategas de
poder seleccionar dentro de una
multiplicidad de opciones
una sola de todas ellas y que es la que
mejor se adapta
a tu economía individual a los tiempos
que te das para comer y a tus
habilidades en la cocina
pero eso nos preguntó
de esos alimentos que compramos todos
los días y que comemos más allá del
envase del que vienen del precio que
tienen o de cómo se preparan
le voy a presentar un caso muy simple
una manzana roja se pregunta en algo
cuando están frente a esta manzana
hace un tiempito estaba justamente una
tarde frente a una manzana como está a
punto de cortarle al medio mientras no
podía dejar de preguntarme por quién
había salido más cara esta manzana que
un alfajor
si tenía que ver con que como dicen
pasta por muchas manos o si era una
cuestión de estacionalidad
también me pregunte cuál es la época en
la que se cosecha una manzana y cuando
quise imaginarme un poco más me di
cuenta que ni siquiera tenía idea de
cómo era la planta de dónde viene la
manzana
y esta situación empezó a pasarme con
cada alimento que tenía enfrente mío sí
ya sé un poco raro no es que esté para
el manicomio logré entender
qué es lo que me pasaba no eran más que
sacudones a mi piloto automático ese que
me había programado como consumidor en
comprar
para comer
y no cuestionarme nada más
esas preguntas me estaban devolviendo la
atención en darme cuenta de que no tenía
ni idea que estaba comiendo más que una
rica y nutritiva manzana en este caso
por eso decidí darles respuestas a todas
estas preguntas pero también saber si
valía la pena que me haga todos estos
cuestionamientos al momento de comer
y les voy a confesar que a pesar de
todos los años que estudie nutrición y
él
y alimentación si a dónde vas cuando no
tienes ni idea
ward definitiva les voy a confesar que
fui a dónde vas cuando no tenés ni idea
que estás buscando pero tenés una
pregunta para hacerte a google y así
encontré
fotos muy tops no no era esta pero no
importa fotos muy tops de campesinos de
boina y zapatos lustrados
encontré relatos de blogs en contra de
la industria también encontré
manuales de cadena productiva que me
fueron útiles y textos de botanas
botánicas con nombres científicos de
planta que
no podía ni leer nada de todo eso podía
de forma suficiente objetiva y creí
increíble darme las respuestas que
estaba buscando
pensé que quizás otras personas estarían
en el mismo lugar que yo
y entonces decidí en marzo de 2017
subirme a un micro hice 18 horas de
viaje
y llegué al alto valle de río negro
no soy millennials así que no fui solo a
sacarme una shell físicos manzanas
fui a visitar productores y el primero
de ellos me dijo ya estás llegando tarde
acá la cosecha terminó y los
cosechadores golondrinas se fueron para
mendoza seguramente por la uva
pero de todas formas me llevo su chacra
y mientras me mostraba todas las
plantaciones y me contaba con detalle
como debía de tener cuidado al sacar
esta fruta de la planta para que no
rompa lo que ellos llaman la semita que
es por donde luego sale la flor y el
próximo año nos vuelve a dar manzanas
por mi costado más controlador no podía
dejar de preguntarle porque era que
había tantas frutas en esta planta sí
la cosecha se había terminado
norberto el productor ante mi ingenuidad
se sonrío es que hacer la segunda pasada
tiene más costos que lo que te van a
pagar por la fruta cuando entres al
empaque pero llévate las que quieras no
hay ningún problema
agarre y les puedo decir que esas frutas
pero las más dulces y jugosas que
convienen mi vida
muy movilizada dije lo próximo que hago
es ir a el empaque y ahí fui observé que
hacen un gran trabajo porque limpian
desinfectar y clasifican a estas frutas
según su tamaño y su color la
seleccionada en primera y segunda
calidad que siguen su proceso hacia la
cera no es que la sep y le dan brillo
quedan las de tercera que son las que
directamente se lleva a la industria
les digo que en eso había algo que no
brillaba y eran los ojos de los
productores
cuando recibían el pago por sus frutas
seis meses después a tres pesos el kilo
en ese entonces de la de primera calidad
que era la que ellos producían acá en
argentina pero se comen en rusia
unos centavos menos las de segunda que
son las que si nos comemos nosotros y
casi un tercio de precio las descarte
las de tercera calidad que son las que
como dije antes utilizan la industria
para hacer sus jugos concentrados y sus
aguas saborizadas
cuál sería mi próximo paso la industria
de cabeza y ahí fui y la verdad es que
me interesaba a conocer el proceso de
todos esos productos pero
más me interesaba preguntarle
porque pagaban tan poco el mal llamado
de descarte de los productores sirve
principal la principal materia prima de
sus productos
esa fue toda su respuesta por lo cual no
me quedé muy conforme y continúe hacia
la secretaría de fruticultura del alto
valle de río negro
me recibió el coordinador de calidad y
la verdad es que muy amablemente y con
mates de por medio obvio
me dio un relato en el que explicaba que
tan difícil era ser moderadores en el
precio al tener que coordinar con
productores empaque cooperativas
intermediarios del mercado concentrador
y la industria dejarlos conformes a
todos
y además ser financiadores de las
pérdidas cuando el granizo cada vez más
frecuente y menos y en épocas menos
esperadas se sucedían
me volví a mi casa
muy reflexiva la verdad que en cada uno
de estos relatos coincidían en que había
más problemas y quejas que incentivos y
redes eran reales
no se quejaban de lleno
entonces como les decía reflexiones
qué gran esfuerzo hacen sobre todos los
productores para seguir sosteniéndose
a pesar de la incertidumbre que sienten
día a día
por no saber si el granizo les va a
quemar sus manzanas
sí
el empaque les va a querer pagar lo que
realmente valen sus frutas y si nosotros
vamos a querer comprarlas en lugar de
elegir las de chile
continúa hacia otras zonas
y lo mismo entre río con sus naranjas
mendoza y san juan con sus uvas misiones
con la yerba mate y podría seguir
diciéndoles formosa y jujuy con sus
bacanales si en formosa y jujuy se
producen banana maracuyá mango banana
palta y tanto más tanto más y a lo largo
y ancho de nuestro país
cerquita nuestro también
solo que sí
[Música]
no tenemos ni idea de eso es porque no
viene en un envase con una etiqueta que
diga made in o hecho en
en toda esta búsqueda en estos
recorridos
descubrí que nuestras decisiones y
elecciones alimentarias
impactan más allá de nuestro bolsillo o
la mesa en la que lo ponemos
impactan en generar un mercado
sostenible más justo
y cercano apoyando a los pequeños
productores generando un trabajo digno
en toda la comunidad que vive en torno a
esta chacra acortando los kilómetros de
traslado y de esa forma reduciendo la
pérdida que genera este traslado así
como la huella ambiental
de su transporte
pero eso se que están pensando todo muy
lindo este cuento y yo que gano
no tengo no sé qué vas a ganar todavía
no sé yo que estoy ganando pero sí sé de
algo y es que no vas a perder nada
imaginemos no de nuevo en este
supermercado frente a la verdulería en
un costado tener unas bananas
grandes bien amarillas de estas que
cuando las compras sabes que te estás
llevando las mejores o al menos esos que
decide el otro lado un poquito más
pequeñitas
o sea más amarronadas podríamos decir
que podríamos pensar en realidad que se
están poniendo feas
las de este lado son las ecuatorianas y
la de este lado
las jujeñas
si le sacas las cáscaras te vas a dar
cuenta que estas chiquitas y amarronadas
que no te querías llevar más allá de que
fuesen las jujeñas
por dentro están buenísimas
están en óptimas condiciones de ser
comestible
y encima son más dulces
pero lo mejor es que son mucho más
baratas
por eso es que debemos ser más críticos
y cuestionar
que estamos comiendo buscar información
para saber cómo es realmente ese
alimento que tiene quién lo hizo de
dónde viene ponerle un rostro y una
historia
y entender qué es lo que verdaderamente
está alimentando lo que hay detrás de
ese alimento
y si se quieren abrir camino honesto
tienen dos opciones juntos
o sumarlo al allá cansadora tarea
de tener que salir a comprar que comer
o tomarlo como un gran poder
de saber que estás eligiendo con
certezas
y que está generando un cambio porque
cuando tomas responsabilidad por lo que
comes te volvés tan poderoso
que el beneficio trasciende
mi punto de partida fue este
hacerme todas esas preguntas frente una
manzana
te pregunto a vos
cuál va a ser tu punto de partida
qué preguntas te vas a hacer cuando
ustedes frente un alimento muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]